back to have Peter Bartlett that would
be a talk about your digital mess thanks
very much for advising me sir yeah I
want to tell you about some some results
on deep residual networks this is joint
work with Steve Evans here at Berkeley
and Phil long at Google so yes we're all
aware of the big successes of deep
neural nets for problems in computer
vision in natural language processing
speech game playing all kinds of things
I want to view in this talk view deep
nets as a composition of nonlinear
functions so just think of an EM layer
network we can think of it as a
composition of M functions each one
takes some vector valued function of its
vector input h2 is composed with that
and so on all the way through to the the
output layer of the network where hm
computes some vector value function of
its vector input and for instance we
might have you know sigmoid
nonlinearities in this network so at the
ice layer the vector valued function we
compute of this vector input X is take a
linear transformation right and then
pass that component-wise through this
sort of non-linearity right so the
output is this squashing function
applied to the it--in put or maybe we
use you know if we're more modern about
it maybe we use a piecewise linear
non-linearity like this ramp function
and then and then this thing is called a
reloj for a rectified linear unit so
again we take many a function pass it
through that scalar linearity pass each
component of this vector through the
scale of non-linearity to compute our
vector output of the function of the eye
slam okay so this is a class of
functions that we're considering and you
know one of the key features here of
these approaches which have been so
successful in practice is that where can
doing deep compositions of functions om
here is you know is a big number it's
not like two anymore right as it was the
last time you're on that's super popular
so okay so what a depth provide us well
the you know the anecdotal evidence is
that we're getting some sort of useful
representations out of these deep
networks that early in the network we
get something that we get simple
features of the input and later they're
these things they're composed into more
complex features and and so this is an
effective way of representing lots of
useful useful features and of learning
useful features you know of course it's
important to think of it as a
nonparametric family although typically
you know I've written this as right we
have you know some fixed set of
parameters but think of the the number
of parameters here is large right this
is really a nonparametric family and
that's how they're used in practice as
the sample size scales people are
typically increasing the the richness of
the parameterization you know and you
get you know these properties that in
many of these applications you can look
at you know number of parameters versus
sample size and those things scale
roughly linearly if you look across you
know many many different empirical
results so it's best to view it as a
rich nonparametric family and within
that sort of statistical approach you
know having having things composed is
providing some sort of a parsimonious
representation so you know it's been
known for a long time the approximation
theorists have these great results about
how nonlinear parameterizations
can give us much better approximation
than the many ones you know going back
to looking at splines with free knots
versus any linear kind of class but more
explicitly the impact of of depth here
you know there are these explicit
constructions of functions that require
hugely more complex representations of
this form if you use a shallow net
versus verses are deeper net or even you
know go one layer shallower you know
there are results the two still gaskey
and others have these examples where you
need a much more complex Network when
you go to a shallower representation so
depth is providing something something
in that in that sense but you know the
flipside is what about the the
optimization issue right if we if we
have a training set and we want to
choose parameters to perform well on
that training set you're ignoring
generalization issues having parameters
appear nonlinearly
is an issue there right so we should
expect that to make the optimization
more difficult and we should expect it
to get worse at least at first glance as
the depth increases okay so and that's
kind of a focus of this talk at least
some issues around that around that
point but in this talk I want to I want
to focus on a specific class of networks
that have proven to be really successful
in computer vision applications so deep
residual networks and talk about some
representation properties and
optimization properties of that family
of networks so what a deep residual
networks well here I've shamelessly
stolen a bunch of slides from chi-ming
whose ICML tutorial so so here this is
this is showing the history of a
particular benchmark problem in computer
vision the image net large-scale vision
recognition challenge from 2000 going
from right to left 2010 back to 2015 up
to 2015 and the blue bars here are
showing a particular measure of
performance this is the top five error
rate in this classification problem so
small is good smaller is better and you
can see there are two big jumps in in
the progress on this particular
benchmark there was the jump from 11 to
12 going from shallow representations
using things like Hogan's sift features
specific features you know appropriate
for these these vision problems with
SVM's and things of that sort on top you
know
ensemble method all the things we're
going from that sort of shallow
representation to Alex net so deep deep
network here which with eight layers big
improvement in
in accuracy on this benchmark you know
steady improvements and then another big
improvement
moving from these nets to residual
networks and you know the other dashed
line there is showing how the depth
increased across that that same period
and increased enormously in moving to
resonate so now there are these very
nice sequence there's a very nice
sequence of images here so this is Alex
net 2012 and in 2014 there are these
other two networks and putting them on
the same scale with this ResNet you know
it's some dramatic right so hugely
deeper and and achieved this much
there's very significant improvement in
performance so what are what a resonance
so standard deep network we're going to
look at two layers at once you know and
we'll see why in the resonant okay
standard deep network we just take our
vector so for a couple of layers we take
take the vector input computer function
by taking a linear linear transformation
of that vector and then pass that
through those let's say real loose
nonlinearities all right and then take
that vector another linear function
passing through the railroad
nonlinearities so let's call that H of X
that's a nonlinear function of X this is
the standard vanilla deep component of a
deep network so when we think about a
residual network in you know what's
different here is just this shortcut
connection so I think of that the input
vector space here as being Rd and the
output as being Rd also same dimension
right and these connections are just the
identity function so what we're doing
here in computing this nonlinear
function of the input is take the input
and add in the same sort of nonlinear
function but in this case it's you know
linear combination of relu of linear
combination of the input okay so but
it's your particular soar a nonlinear
function plus the identity so why is
that significantly different from
the vanilla deep network well you know
one immediate observation is that you
have zero weights in the two cases what
happens what for for a regular deep
network zero way to computer zero
function all right you're just taking
this homogeneous transformation that not
only transformation of these linear
functions set the parameters to zero you
know consider the zero linear function
and the whole thing computes the zero
function but in the case of these deep
residual networks as setting the
parameters to zero gives you the
identity and that something that we
should be viewing as a as a big plus
because you know having some having zero
or small weights means we're close to
the identity and identity connections
are providing us with useful feedback
right throughout the network okay so
typically these things are trained with
stochastic gradient methods starting off
with small values of these parameters
and if you think about what happens for
you know parameters early on in a
network like this here's the input is
the output this is a plane network
without those direct connections and
this is a residual network you know what
what happens to a parameter back here
that's trying to decide you know should
I be moving this way or that way in
response to you know this input and and
this is the desired output you know of
course it depends on all of these
near-zero functions that are composed in
front of it whereas the with the
identity connections you know you can
imagine you're getting some sort of
feedback from those direct connections
from the from the output you know that's
the intuition that's the the argument
that was made in the paper that
introduced residual networks and there's
empirical evidence to to back up that
sort of that sort of intuition so here's
a comparison on a small data set type I
attend a classification problem looking
at just vanilla deep networks with
different number of layers and and
residual networks and the plots here
show the
- lines are the training error and the
solid lines of test error on a
validation set
and the different colors correspond to
different depths of these networks okay
so the the bottom line here is for depth
20 and then 30 to 40 456 so train and
again for test you know things go up in
the same order right and you know that
sort of striking is really points to a
failure of optimization because you know
we know with these networks if we've got
a 22 layer Network it can compute a
particular function of course we can
compute the same function with more
layers right because we can compute the
identity at any layer so you know as we
get to richer and richer representations
we're just not able to exploit that with
the optimization question initialization
your neural network that works pretty
well is that I guess that's a way of
thinking of it yeah yeah so you know
when you're working with a gradient at a
constant function onto it you know
you're not changing any of the gradients
so that's that's another another way to
think of it so the comparison of these
these networks with with residual
networks again the colors represent the
depths and you know in this case as the
depth increases the performance on
training data improves and the
performance on test data also improves
and this one's gone out to you know 110
layers which I don't think gave any
useful useful result in in this other
case all right so this suggests that you
know it's optimization that's really
playing a key role here and these things
were yeah question Misha
I think that I think that straight yeah
so it certainly as training proceeds I
don't know whether they're talking about
passes through the data further or what
yeah I don't know I'd have to look up
paper sorry so there's been many events
but I believe they're both using
mini-batch and I suspect that this is
showing the number of iterations of the
number of mini batches so we used first
account degrading yeah but you know I
suggest checking the paper here okay
and and these things were you know when
they're introduced very successful in in
these competitions so the image net1 so
this is a visual recognition and
localization problem you had to say you
know was there a person or a chair and
where where are they in the in the image
and you know much better than than any
any competitor significant improvement
over previous previous years and Coco
another another competition this one for
detection and segmentation again
considerably better than than any other
approach okay so you know why what's
what's behind the success of these
networks what's important for their
performance and I want to tell you about
a couple of results that are little
steps in that direction
I guess so first let's talk a bit about
some intuition that comes from a linear
case so there's this elegant paper by
Morris heart and Tanguma and they could
say thought about this case of residual
network so they said well what about
forgetting about these awkward
nonlinearities and think of just linear
functions at each at each layer right
suppose we throw out the nonlinearities
and consider composition of linear
functions of course the whole thing is
just a linear function so it's a a very
kind of convoluted way of representing a
linear function but let's let's go with
that
so we can think about a linear function
we could represent each each the linear
function at each layer by a matrix the
whole thing is just a product of
matrices that's the linear function
we're computing and the result is that
you know if you have an invertible
linear function then you could write it
as a composition of linear functions all
of which are close to the identity in
some sense you know the sense is that
the spectral norm of the matrix right
the difference between the identity and
and what you're computing at each layer
goes down like one over m the number of
layers here all right so if you get a
deeper deeper composition of these
linear functions then you can represent
your your linear function of interest as
a composition of things that are closer
and closer to the identity in the sense
of the spectral law and you know there's
a little there's some fine print here
about a certain orientation condition
the determinant of the matrix needs to
have the right side to be able to make
its conclusion okay so that's so that's
one one result that they had in the the
linear case that that you can represent
a an invertible linear function as a
composition of new identity linear
functions and then they had a nice
consequence of that again in the linear
case for the properties of a certain
error landscape so let's think about a
problem of you know we have a linear
gaussian model right so input vector X
output vector Y they're both in Rd
there's a certain linear relationship
between X and the conditional mean of Y
right it's a eight times X and Y is
conditionally Gaussian right with that
that conditional mean and you know some
some certain covariance okay so under
this model you could think about what
happens when instead of just estimating
a linear parameter here a single matrix
we consider choosing a composition of
these linear functions our product of
matrices right to minimize the quadratic
loss okay so the expectation of
difference between the outcome and the
linear prediction the Euclidean norm
squared of that difference and the
result is that if the spectral norm of
these matrices these deviations from the
identity but if the spectral norm is
strictly less than one then every
stationary point is a global optimum so
what does that mean if you look at the
gradient of this thing with respect to
its parameters so you know you could
imagine writing out a huge vector of
gradients with respect to every one of
those parameters right here I've written
Bloch waves right for all I for each of
these a is the gradient with respect to
all of those parameters of this thing if
that's zero everywhere so you're at a
stationary point then that implies that
this product is actually equal to a
right you've you've got the correct
value of the of the the parameters here
so that's very nice it tells you that
that you can that provided you stay
close to the identity everywhere then a
stationary point is an optimum for this
problem okay so that's the you know that
really fits in very well with the
intuition you have about the advantages
of keeping things close to the identity
that that you don't get troubled by
local local Optima or saddle points
so did it put I'm just trying to
understand the word implied mean it
seems that curtain triangular doesn't
mean that I will if I start close enough
I will actually go to the store oh no
okay yes that's right
so it's not telling it's not an
optimization result it's a result about
this error landscape it tells you that
if you come across the stationary point
in this near identity region then that
stationary point is necessarily an
optimal point right it's the it's the
right value of a but but you're right it
may be that if you follow a gradient
then you'll just get let out slide this
narrowed identity region okay so it's
telling you about
you know property of stationary points
in that region then no actually it's
independent of Sigma and and sort of for
a trivial reason right because we're
looking at stationary points of the
expectation and so we know we can
decompose we can decompose this into a
bias term in a very assess right and so
you know the variance term can be huge
and it could lead to all sorts of issues
if we want to do things where the final
sample is going to you know make it
harder and harder but you know we're
averaging all those issues away lateral
edge balancing the surface is going to
be the same because it's an additive
term but you're ignoring it right when
you when you get the gradient of this
thing you can express as a gradient of a
bias part which is how far this thing is
you know with an appropriate covariance
in the middle there but it's like just a
quadratic form involving how far you are
from a the optimal thing together with a
variance term for the optimal thing and
that variance term you know will get
bigger and bigger but it's just additive
and so when you take gradients it plays
no role at all okay so so really the
rest of the talk is all about showing
that those sort of properties are true
in the nonlinear case right that you can
go from that you can make the same sort
of statements when the functions you're
computing at each layer or not linear
functions but but nonlinear functions
Lipschitz functions okay so the first
part is is about representing nonlinear
functions with a deep composition of
nonlinear functions so so you know we're
talking about a smooth invertible this
is the sort of hand wavy version and
I'll be more precise on the next slide
so so we've got a smooth invertible map
you know the result is that if you want
to compute that you can spread that out
across M layers a depth M composition of
nonlinear functions so that all of the
layers are computing near identity
functions if you look at the difference
between that function and the identity
it's close to in some sense zero and and
you know goes down as something like 1
over m the depth of the network right so
you know rather similar to the Shalini
okay so what is this normal this is
actually a semi norm
it's the Lipschitz seminal it tells you
that you know this thing the difference
here should be should be getting flatter
and flatter as things get deeper so you
know this this Lipschitz semi norm is
the Lipschitz constant of the that
function right best least value that you
can put in here okay so as as the net
gets and the composition gets deeper you
can you can get functions that are
closer and closer to the identity in the
sense that the difference is getting
flatter and flatter right these these
nonlinear differences are getting
flatter and flatter so you can think of
those maps these H is here as being you
know near ideally maps that you might
you might compute them in this sort of a
way right so we might have our watching
linear function of X squashing function
applied component wise to that linear
function of that right so these things
are universal approximate us and and so
as we allow the inner dimension here to
get bigger and bigger weekend we can
approximate
you know any one of these that that we
want in a in a uniform way on on a
compact set right so of course you know
think of that as identity plus some
nonlinear function of that sort and you
know punchline is as the network gets
deeper those the the non identity part
the deviation from identity can get
flatter and so on okay so now to make
that a little more precise so our
function we're considering any a bounded
domain right so there's some ball and
everything we're interested in is
contained within that ball the function
H has to be differentiable it has to be
invertible which is a strong condition
it has to be smooth okay so so when we
look at two places x and y the
derivative of our function at those two
places varies in a way that that
satisfies this Lipschitz constraint
right the difference of the derivatives
is bounded in norm by some constant
times the difference in those those
values and this is the induced norm
right so we're looking at the supremum
of these ratios and they don't you know
it will be a little careful about the
definition this is not these are linear
functions so it's you know it really is
the ratio here for arbitrary X we need H
not just to be invertible but to have a
Lipschitz inverse okay so you know again
this Lipschitz semi norm of the of the
inverse of h is bounded by some constant
we need this orientation condition again
so at some point the determinant of the
derivative is positive and then we get
the result that there are M functions
that are close to the identity in this
order 1 over m or log M over m sort of a
way and we can represent this this H
satisfying this condition there is a
composition of these of these M
functions
and you know and in the big o-notation
the constant here depends on the the
constants m and alpha and the and the
extent the radius of the standard domain
alright so that's what we can say in the
nonlinear case let me give it yep and
also define the conditions and sorry
like each one - HM digital information
they do so so actually so these
functions you know not just their
they're smoother than just just
satisfying the sort of Lipchitz
condition
they're as smooth as h actually we'll
see we can we come up with an explicit
construction for the agents
so actually we can't because we want to
think of things as being close to the
identity right so think of the case
where you're in three dimensions you
know the identity has a certain
orientation right and in that case you
could negate one of your input features
and and then compute the function which
has you know the right sign here right
in our dimensions anyway I'm sorry
you can but you know I mean we're just
writing a specific result here right you
need to put a minus sign in somewhere
yeah right so the same thing is true you
know trivially if you replace H with
minus H then it's true for minus H right
but yeah you know there's says there's a
constraint here it's not all all mapping
satisfying these other conditions I
think you've said this before but why is
this advantage yeah so so we'll see that
in the second part but the intuition
from the linear cases you know again
this this result about the the shape of
the error surface that when you're close
to the identity then you have this
property that for compositions
compositions of this sort when they're
all close to the identity you know we'll
see that you have an analogous behavior
of this error surface that all
stationary points are globally optimal
so we'll see we'll see something of that
flavor and later that's what Misha was
saying yeah for this you cannot because
it's eternal you cannot give the minus
one to the power T in in or dimensions
you can yes that's right but not in even
dimensions of a generic harder to handle
the others will get yes yes that's right
thank you
okay so let's let's have a look at the
outline of the proof so without loss of
generality we're going to assume that H
takes value 0 at 0 and its derivative at
0 is the identity ok shifting things to
make H of 0 equal to 0 doesn't change
anything because you know a shift has
Lipschitz norms ero and transforming
things to make the derivative equal to
the identity at 0 is just a linear
transformation and we know we can
represent those using near identity
linear functions all right so you know
we're fine to make that assumption and
then you know now you can sort of see
where where this is going we can do an
easy transformation to get something
that's close to the derivative at 0
which is the identity if we think about
scaling X just by this this is a scalar
a 1 right so we take our original
function a and scalar down by this
constant and then divide by the constant
right so as a 1 goes to 0 we're
computing something like the derivative
at 0 here in in that map h1 so we're
going to construct our h1 h2 and so on
so that you know in first condition
second condition is that the composition
of h2 with h1 is another scaled version
right scale the inputs go the output
keep on going like that all the way
through to the end and after M a
composition of M of these functions we
want it to be H of am x over am so we
better have a m equal to 1 so the
composition is exactly H and now we're
just going to choose the AI
appropriately right so the first one has
to be small enough that we're getting
you know roughly the identity here the
derivative at 0 and then subsequent ones
has to be the the gap so that's the
difference between these these AIS and
going from something near 0 to something
that's equal to 1 the difference should
be small enough that the transformation
from here to here say is close to the
identity and then you know and that
part's sort of easy and then there's a
bit more work to show that that these
functions are actually
close the identity in this literature
sense we have to work separately with
what happens on small scales and large
scales with small means you know the
difference between the subsequent
parameters you know if you're less than
that value or if you're lighter than
that value so there's a you know a
little bit of ugly computation there all
right so that's the that's the key idea
of that result the punch line is but
deeper networks allow us to have flatter
non-linear functions at each layer we
can compute a function of this sort
exactly
using a composition of these identity
plus flatten or linear function okay and
the second piece is is the this result
about the error landscape for such new
identity functions so here we're going
to think about you know an XY pair right
so inputs and outputs and they have some
fixed Joint Distribution and we consider
a quadratic criterion so half the
expected squared Euclidean norm of the
difference between the outcome and H of
X right so so we're wanting to predict Y
using this function H of X and and this
is for the particular Joint Distribution
that we have you know this is the
quality of our function H we can define
the minimizer H star the function that
minimizes this quantity you know that's
going to be a conditional expectation of
Y given X and you know I haven't said
anything about this Joint Distribution
we could think about it as just being
uniform on a training sample right so
all we're doing is empirical risk
minimization when we want to find H star
we want to minimize this and H star is
some empirical risk minimizer
okay so now let's think about a function
H that is a composition of M of these
near identity functions right and I'll
just write it as epsilon then what can
we say you can say well let's compute
the derivative of this criterion with
respect to the function H I so there's a
functional gradient a fresh a derivative
I think I put yeah pressure derivative
and we're looking at the you know
induced norm of this linear functional
right so we take the fresh a derivative
of this criterion with respect to the
guy that appears in the ice step of this
composition the norm of that linear
functional that derivative is bounded
below by something that scales as qh- Q
H star right so if you're suboptimal
right if H is worse than H star then you
know your gradient is bounded away from
zero okay and this is showing I guess
the uphill gradient but of course it's a
linear functional you know there's a
downhill direction a function that that
when you compute this linear functional
in that in that direction takes you take
you down hill and and you know and it's
steep if if Q of H gets steeper as Q of
H gets further from from Q H time okay
so what is what is that saying so with
our composition is suboptimal and and we
have this condition that each H I is a
near identity now it's skated over that
right so these things are all epsilon
close to an identity in this Lipschitz
sense and we get you know the epsilon
appearing here right in the as epsilon
gets gets closer to 1 things get get
worse then there's some downhill
direction in function space so the
functional gradient of Q with respect to
H is nonzero so every stationary points
a global optimum there's no local
minimum there's no saddle point within
this near idenity region in function
space
and actually you know from the proof and
I won't really go into this but turns
out that that it's the steep directions
in in the original function space of
space of compositions that are providing
a witness to the steep directions at
every layer so you know just the sort of
thought formalizing just a sort of
intuition that we we talked about at the
beginning for resonance okay so what
does the theorem not say it doesn't say
that you won't have local minima of a
deep residual network with a particular
parameterization fix an architecture you
know and and look in the parameter space
we're not talking about you know when
your computer gradient it's a gradient
with respect to something here it's here
it's a functional gradient we're not
talking about a gradient with respect to
some finite dimensional parameter space
okay and and you know we should actually
expect to have to have suboptimal
stationary points for such
parameterizations and we can say
something precise about that at least in
the signal in space
so what it does tell us is that you know
unless you're at the global minimum
there's some downhill direction in in
function space but you know that
direction might be orthogonal to all the
functions you can compute with this
fixed architecture right not true if you
want to go to if you allow the the
architecture to grow right but for a
fixed architecture certainly true so as
I say we certainly should expect some
optimal stationary points for this sort
of parameterization but they're not
arising because of interactions between
parameters and different layers they're
arising solely because of what happens
within a layer because of the the
parametrization that you've chosen and
the and sort of difficult properties
that that that imposes on the reform of
the error surface okay so that's the
results now I had it a little bit to say
in a few minutes I had a little bit say
about the proof just just a couple of
ideas really so you know it's based on
the the properties of these near
identity maps if you've got something
that's close to a node already in this
Lipschitz sense
say closer than alpha and then it's
necessarily invertible
you can bound Lipschitz constants of
that function and it's inverse all right
in terms of how close it is to the
identity when you consider the great
functional gradients with respect to to
the argument of this fungus oh so if we
compute a composition of that function
that's close to the identity with some
function G and consider that thing it's
functional gradient so the pressure
derivative of that evaluated at G that
thing is close to the identity that
linear functional right I'm close in the
induced norm but of course it's a funk
it's a linear function and for any
linear map including including this one
the induced Norman the Lipschitz normal
the same thing right because you're you
know these these functions all go
through zero okay so so you know these
these are the the crucial properties
that let us keep control of what happens
before and after the function that we're
taking the derivative with respect to
okay so you know the main main idea of
the proof first of all we have
projection theorem so same as in the
linear case right we we have that this
quadratic loss that we incur can be
split up into you know the how far we
are from the optimal thing conditional
expectation plus a variance term you
know the the quality of H stock that's
the constant there is actually Q of H
star
and then that means we can take the
fresh air derivative of this thing with
respect to the function in the ice stage
of this composition and we get something
so this evie sub X is the evaluation
functional it's composed with the
derivative of the full composition with
respect to that H I and this is the
thing where you know we're keeping
control here of how close all of the all
of the pieces in this composition ask
the identity and you know we can
actually explicitly compute this thing
explicitly plug in a function a
direction that
you want to take this linear evaluate
this linear functional app and and set
things up so that that has unit norm and
it's in exactly the opposite direction
to the where written at the same
direction as this right so that actually
you know the derivative evaluated in
this in this direction gives us
something that is on the scales as the
XS here the difference between H and H
star and that constant C is where we
make use of you know all these
properties of new identities to say you
know C can't be too small because we've
got all the functions in the rest of
this composition being close to an
identity so that's where these 1 minus
epsilon all pop up pop up from all right
so that's the sum of some of the ideas
of the the proof they're I guess they're
a bunch of you know obvious questions
here right so you know we need this
assumption that the mapping is
invertible the mapping that we're
wanting to approximate to estimate is
invertible but you know there are lots
of cases if that requires of course that
you're mapping from Rd to Rd what if you
do solving a simple classification
problem or something like you just want
a single dimension you know what happens
in that case well it's it's kind of
trivial that you can extend it in that
case to a d-dimensional mapping and if
you can come up with an extension that
is invertible right there has this by
Lipschitz or a property then then you
know of course you can represent things
with slap functions at each layer right
and suggest a particular approach to
doing that that you're keeping your
network computing d dimensional vectors
all the way along and at the end you
know throwing away d minus one of them
which might not be the first thing you
would think of so such a mapping so but
of course then what what if it can't do
that right what if you can't extend your
mapping to something that is invertible
and we really don't know particularly
you know what the implications for
optimization there are related classes
that the optimization theorists of
have wrestled with that there are these
whole yak yurievich function classes
that have some relationship between how
far you are above a local optimum and
the derivative that you see and and you
know there are specific algorithms for
those classes they converge quickly the
stationary points you know they're not
quite the same as the condition that we
have is not quite the same as the
condition defining these classes and you
know obvious question what about the
methods the optimization methods that
people actually use in practice do they
produce near identities ok and so I
guess the to punch lines here are that
you know in terms of representation
deeper networks are allowing a lower
representation with flatter functions
with each layer and under this sort of
condition if you restrict yourself to
flat nonlinear parts I should say right
the non-identity part right of these
functions if you if you restrict
yourself to identity plus something very
flat then stationary points a global
minima all right thank you
[Applause]
I had one question about the tribute to
get without money so here you're staying
hostage
wonderful no not necessary yeah so did
you go back to the original motivation
with this sort of 150 fewer layers yes
they go back and look at that and if it
obviously yeah to see if to see if this
really happens if you can extend it to
an RDD thing oh okay okay so you know
actually it depends on which problem
you're talking about some of these
vision problems are naturally Rd to Rd
you know if you're talking about
identifying a person in an image it's
it's not a crazy thing to be to be
answering the question everywhere in the
image and have and have a map from you
know one vector space to another X place
of the same dimension but yes lots of
those lots of those some problems are
not of that of that nature no and and
you know somehow you wouldn't you
wouldn't really expect it right it it
feels like it would it's it feels like a
pretty strong condition to have to have
to be able to extend your map to
something that's invertible yeah yeah
that's what we can you know it's a small
says that it's a small step right
there's what we can prove something
about but it does seem like you know a
pretty a pretty strong constraint why
won't this work for just a trivial thing
like the summer being good I could have
a classification we just add in this
case yeah I mean you can come up with
examples where that doesn't work but I
don't know that this could show it would
be true in general I don't make that's
interesting we should talk
back